gonna lose representative o'hara at some
point i was hoping you could uh fill in
for him
uh at least be promoting and demoting
anybody that wants to speak
goodbye yeah i can do that for you yeah
i'll jump out around 10
thank you and we are
um the recording is live and it is live
all right good morning everybody welcome
back i hope everybody enjoyed a
slight reprieve from our community work
um today
uh we'll be taking up our senate bill
131 the only one issued the
transportation
before we get started i need to read our
script
as chair of the house transportation
committee i find it due to the state of
emergency declared by the governor
as a result of the covet 19 pandemic and
in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to
executive order 2020-04 this public body
is authorized to me electronically
this is a public hearing with the
potential for executive session to occur
throughout
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen contemporaneously to
this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
one all members of the committee and
select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listened
and necessary to participate in this
meeting by the zoom platform or by
telephone
uh all necessary access information has
been made available on the host calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
two the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules and rsa bank one a
three anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call so three two
seven
one three six zero zero or email
hcs ledge dot state
dot nh dot u s in the event
the public isn't able to access the
meeting the meeting will be adjourned
and rescheduled
i want to introduce the staff who are
meeting
our researcher brad greenland and
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by professor
uh speaking of that let's start the
meeting by taking what we'll call
attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the movie during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
okay good morning representative
ankenberg
representative aaron not president
i'm here in rochester and i'm alone in
my office thank you
work is here representative fenton
i am present and alone in my office
i am present and i am here with my
daughter and granddaughter who are not
in the room
thank you our vice chair gagney
president in the house representative
president alone in my office thank you
representative
representative o'hara here my wife and
son are in the house i'm alone in my
office
representative pickering was in the
meeting and he's not here anymore i
texted him to see if he was having
trouble
i haven't heard back maybe he'll come
back later
representative rich i'm here in my house
my husband and son are in the house
somewhere
thank you representative smith
she shows us being present but i see
that
she was having some technical
difficulties yesterday um
i might i'll try to reach out to her on
another method
all right thank you representative sites
present downstairs in the house alone
i'm here and i do have family members in
the house thank you
representative i'm here
alone in my office but my wife is also
in the house thank you
and chairman walsh uh here uh paul
that looks like representative stevens
has got her audio
i don't i don't i am here i am here in
my home
but we do have ability first it's
actually
six bills and i was hoping uh to take
them up one at a time and try to keep
some kind of order
as opposed to you know pulling out
calling on people and going from one
section of the bill
to the other so i guess my question is
for
brad at this point if would it work if i
ask people that are
um remote to not put their hands up
until we get to that section
is there resentment can you repeat that
question yeah is that is it a doable
thing for me to
ask people who want to speak or have
signed up
do not raise their hand until we get to
that
that section of bill i mean um i believe
you
certainly can i believe that would be up
to your discretion well
that's what i want to do i'm just trying
to you know not call on somebody second
that wants to talk about
section six i'd like to try to get
through this one section at a time so
we'll we'll give it a shot okay um so
if everybody heard anybody that is uh
participating remotely
um i do have a list but if you could not
put your hand up
and just watch how we go uh my intention
is to take these up one section at a
time to
try to keep it organized so
with that being said mr chairman
representative he has her hand up real
quick sorry
mr chairman your audio is a little muted
i don't know if you could adjust your
microphone up just a little bit
any better i believe so anyone if anyone
else
all right thank you let me repeat what i
just said then uh anybody uh
participating remotely
i am going to try to go through this one
section at a time so if you're here to
speak on
say section two three or other uh
please don't raise your hand until we
get to that part i'm just trying to
keep a little bit of water to this if
possible so
that being said um i believe it would be
there he is good morning mr chairman
members of the
transportation committee it's good to
see you all i'm senator david
waters from district four and uh
here to introduce senate bill 131
part one and perhaps i say a word about
part four if i may at the end
mr chairman because i i'm supposed to be
in capital budget now but uh
i i appreciate this opportunity to
present uh this bill
for you um part one has to do with
electric vehicle
infrastructure uh and the bill arises
from
uh the commission on electric vehicle
infrastructure that
we established three years ago your
members representative smith and
representative sykes were
on that commission and we produced a
report which i believe has been
sent to committee members and so this
bill represents a few small items from
that
report to help us be ready for um
this this business and uh tourism and uh
other
uh you know effects of the arrival of
electric
um electric vehicles um becky oller who
has been spearheading electric vehicle
infrastructure
issues in the department of
environmental services is i believe
available to you this morning if you
have some more questions about
the background here i want to start
first by
noting governor sununu's leadership
on this issue when we received the
vw settlement funds there was a maximum
amount that could be designated to
electric vehicle infrastructure and
governor sununu
decided to put that maximum amount about
5.6 million dollars
to this so that and really in three
buckets he said
some should go to the department of
transportation other
state agencies if they need the
infrastructure
some might go to electric school buses
and then the largest part would go to
help building out
electric vehicle charging infrastructure
on our main
transportation corridors with fast
charge stations and then to look at
some level 2 chargers on secondary roads
in new hampshire at businesses and other
places uh
convenient to to travelers uh so
um osi and des have worked on requests
for proposals to get that
um that vw money um
uh spent um the bill um
outlines uh some of the findings from
the
uh commission um about what this is
gonna mean for new hampshire businesses
uh auto dealers um tourists and
and so forth who want to come to new
hampshire and
be able to charge up their vehicles and
you know shop and
vacation and do their business in the in
the state as well
some of the context as well is that some
of the states around us are selling high
numbers of electric vehicles not so many
in the state of new hampshire yet
um quebec their new vehicle sales about
electric and um you know we're seeing
the industry move this direction
um i saw yesterday notice the f-150 the
best-selling
vehicle united states is going to be
manufactured in electric vehicles
starting this
spring and gm has committed to electric
vehicles
by 2025 and some other auto companies by
2035 as well so the auto industry
uh is wants to be sure that um the state
is ready
on our transportation corridors as as
as well um and uh i also would just like
to mention with a little new hampshire
angle on it i'm sure a lot of you know
merchants fleet
and it's one of the largest fleet
operators in the in the nation and um
business new hampshire their uh ceo had
an
article about how you know technological
innovation this is the next big thing
for fleet management because of the
amount of money they can save
uh on these these vehicles so that's
just a
way of saying that the this bill is
meant to do some some small changes
that'll get us on the
path to having this infrastructure ready
and i'll turn to the bill and um you'll
see the first part
are some findings which um lay out the
some of the rationales from the
commission report
about promoting tourism generating jobs
support consumers
businesses automo dealers and
manufacturers
by having this infrastructure available
in the state it also mentions the work
that the commission
did with the utilities who are very
much interested in helping build out
this
infrastructure we had a lot of
participation from unitil eversource
and new hampshire electric co-op which
is very aggressive in its programs about
uh charging infrastructure for
um its its customers um the heart of the
bill
really is in sections two and uh three
um section two kind of
reiterates what we did in um senate bill
three years ago um that was a bill that
set out some basic you know requirements
about
signage about parking about public
availability
of charging stations and what we wanted
to make sure
is that the money that the state is
putting out from the vw
settlement or potentially from other
federal
um uh awarded funds
that these ought to be available to
everybody there shouldn't be any
proprietary technology
you'll see now if you go to our rest
areas uh in
on 93 um the charging stations there are
tesla charging stations and we wanted to
make sure that
um anybody who had any kind of vehicle
would be able to pull up
and uh use the facility if it's being
funded by the vw
settlement funds uh section three
responds to something that we heard a
lot from businesses
and from municipalities um they are very
eager
uh to start building out their in
infrastructure
and so this section uh enables
municipalities under 79e as they do for
other things
to provide an abatement for the added
value to assessed property um
for electric uh vehicles um
infrastructure
and um this is something that you know
businesses uh said
you know and and uh potentially people
who want to put the infrastructure in
department complexes
uh and elsewhere um that this would
enable municipalities as a lot of them
are doing for
for solar and for other kinds of
infrastructure projects uh
that they could have a a a an abatement
of
increased value assessed value of
property for a limited period
of time if they chose to do that
um section 4 takes some of the language
that
is before the public utilities
commission
senate bill 575 three years ago
required the poc to open a docket on the
charging
structure and the rate structure how are
they going to handle
electric vehicle infrastructure and uh
there was a draft report from staff
that laid out some principles and that's
what we put
in here um believing that really you
know it's the legislature that makes
policy
um not the agencies and that if these
seemed like
common sense ways that this is kind of
what other states are doing and what the
staff at the puc
thought was the way to go that we ought
to have it in statutory
um language um that said you know the
puc is going to do its work
and uh you know with the new department
of energy whatever entity they call it
uh
the dockets will continue and so on and
um so if the members of the committee
feel it's premature to do this um
i know that there you know madeleine
leno will be before you thinking there's
one
piece of this that maybe ought to be
changed
but if the committee thinks that this is
premature or
you know not ready to want to put this
in statute i
i'm not sure section four at this time
is absolutely necessary so really the
bill
becomes section two in section three of
part one um let me just
mention as a last uh moment too is that
there is a remnant
um physical note to 131
uh originally this section of the bill
proposed
as we had passed a couple years ago to
move towards electrifying the state
fleet
we decided in the senate to take that
out and the physical node has not caught
up with it so for this section of the
bill there is no physical impact for the
state
at all so i just wanted to
mention that because i i know how
physical notes uh sometimes remain with
bills and uh get a little
out of date and um wanted to clear that
up as
as well so mr chairman i i know becky
oller and some others are
here from the charging industry and
elsewhere who might be available but i'd
be happy to take any
any questions that uh anyone might have
thank you senator any questions from the
committee
i'll let you off the hook that easy i
see chairman
as i mentioned yesterday is it possible
for me to um
briefly say a couple words about uh part
four that's fine do you know if there's
gonna be anybody else
uh testifying to the bill when we get to
i'm you will have safety here okay well
then
fair enough then sure yeah so i'll just
say very um
and thank you so much mr chairman i know
how hard it is for you to deal with
these
omni offals that the senate sends over
anyways you know i i feel a little bit
sheepishly it seemed like a good idea
back in november but here we are right
um so um part four is essentially
housekeeping uh at the request of uh
um safety um we had a
uh card a golden granite state card
a number of years ago that allowed
people
um to uh get discounts if they had one
of these cards if you were
a senior citizen and um that program
ended about a decade ago and uh no
longer is this
so this this removes that language from
statute
i will say uh having turned 70 fairly
recently i never got to use this card
but
there it is and then um essentially what
it establishes is that
um you have one form of picture id that
you
you you would have one form of uh of
picture id
um and not two uh if you
required one from the if you wanted one
from the department of safety
so um you'll i believe um say you know
safety is here
um it's it is housekeeping but that's
that's the gist of that part of it mr
chairman
thank you very much uh i see one
thank you very much thank you senator
waters for taking my question
um when i was reviewing this section one
little piece jumped out at me um and i
hope i would love to get your take on it
um on the very first part where it
clarifies
who is eligible for a non-driver picture
id card
you have a anyone 12 years of age or
older who does not possess a driver's
license
b is disabled and does not possess a
driver's license
or c which is being struck out is 65
years of age or older
and has could have a driver's license i
understand you're taking out that
part c when i read it line b
concerned me because i believe anyone
who's disabled
falls under line a um our granite
staters who are of the disability
community
are also 12 years of age or older
and i think that this line b might be
left over from times when they were
the disabled community was called out
unnecessarily
and i did reach out to director bolecki
about this
and i have drafted an amendment which
would
take out line b i just wanted to run
that by you
to see if that would be something you
would be agreeable to
well certainly and thank you um
representative for the question
and for catching that because um i had
not really thought about it and i think
clearly it is a remnant it seems to me
of
an earlier way of dealing with ids and
uh
really wouldn't be appropriate for the
reasons that you you suggest so thank
you very much
okay thank you very much any other
questions
seeing none thank you again senator and
thank you
mr chairman and i'm available if anybody
has any questions that come up after the
hearing
you know give me a call and i very much
very much appreciate the
the committee's work thank you thank you
okay let's try this as i had asked
before
anybody that's i'd like to testify
to this that's remote mr chairman we
can't hear you you speak up a little bit
sure uh let's try this now like i
suggested before
uh if anybody wishes to speak to this
i'm looking at my attendee list
could you raise your hand now and then i
can start going through it
oh representative bows too
yeah i do see a representative um
assuming he may have other things to do
uh the chair recognizes uh
who is if we have him here
opposed
thank you mr chairman can you hear me i
can good morning
good morning good morning everyone and
thank you for
uh allowing me to make a few remarks
this morning about uh
senate bill 131 for the record i am
representative michael bose
i represent rockingham district 9 the
town of epping
and i serve as chair of the science
technology and
energy committee i signed in in
opposition to
uh this bill i only want to make remarks
about section one i have no
uh remarks or comments about the other
sections
of the bill i'm only going to make
comments about
section one my concern with section one
is primarily sections three and sections
four the
uh prime sponsor senator waters
mentioned
in his testimony that section four may
be premature and i would concur with
that
judgment i think um adding section four
to the st
to statute at this point is is premature
because
the principles outlined in that
statutory language
would then require the public utilities
commission to
bake into electricity rates the costs
of some infrastructure
electric vehicle recharging
infrastructure going forward
and the intent of the bill originally
was to
use the 4.6 million dollars allocated
from the volkswagen
settlement agreement to build that
infrastructure
and so while that seems appropriate it
does not seem to me
to be appropriate at this time anyway to
build
that into electricity rates for the
future so i would
recommend eliminating
section four if you decided to go
forward with this bill
but another problem with the bill is
section three and that's the tax relief
portion of the bill i realize that it's
optional for cities or towns to
provide that tax relief should they
decide to do so
presumably by a majority vote of their
governing body
but nevertheless i would remind members
that
any time you provide property tax relief
for one segment
of the population you're increasing the
property tax burden
on the other segment of property
taxpayers
so be careful when you
implement this kind of policy it
doesn't seem to be necessary for this
particular
infrastructure if it's going to be
funded by
settlement money from the volkswagen
settlement
so i would encourage you to remove
section 3 from the bill as well
if you decide to go forward with it
those two sections i see as
problematical
it could be that and i will admit i
haven't read the report
from the the committee that senator
waters referred to earlier
but i have looked at the documents that
osi
and des generated about the
volkswagen settlement mitigation effort
and i've looked at the documents about
uh
recent rfps that have been issued and
received no response
to indicate that there's no dramatic
need for this infrastructure at this
time
so i would i would argue that
it may be prudent to consider
postponing this infrastructure bill
until a later date so that it can be
made
more practical
and satisfy the requirements of
the mitigation effort that osi and des
have
laid out there doesn't seem to be any
great
human cry for this infrastructure at the
moment
so you might want to consider
eliminating this
this section of the bill entirely um
but if you do retain parts of the bill i
would
recommend eliminating sections three in
sections four
and with that i'll answer any questions
if i can
thank you thank you representative
um i do see
representative gagne thank you mr
chairman
can you hear me uh repton balls
yes i can larry thank you thank you i'm
using my
your opposition to parts of this bill
of this section i see two
section threes are you talking about
line eight
on page two or line
well i'm looking at the version of the
bill that i
i got off of the general court website
and doesn't have line numbers
um okay i'm looking at the
section three called community
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative votes um
if for taking my question um
would i it was a two-part question if
you bear with me
would you recognize representative votes
that
tourism is an important part of the new
yes thank you for that question i
certainly recognize that tourism
is important to our economy
[Music]
but i forgot that i normally i shut it
off
when i'm at the state house but anyways
i i sent it to voicemail
go ahead i apologize
no problem go ahead okay so
with that in mind um while they're
the adoption of electric vehicles in new
hampshire has been
slower than other states there's um
[Music]
i suspect that the numbers
of tourists who would be coming to the
state and who will need this
infrastructure is rising dramatically in
the next
few years and i i wondered how you felt
about that
i don't doubt that there will be um
an increase in tourists driving electric
vehicles in the future
and i think we can provide for them but
i don't think this particular bill
is the best way to build that charging
infrastructure
thank you for taking my questions
representative
thank you representative erin thank you
mr chairman good morning everyone and
good morning representative vos
can you hear me as uh well
yes i can hear you fine okay thank you
um so my question is regarding
the volkswagen settlement money do you
know if there is any kind of time limit
i thank you for that question
representative i'm not aware of any time
limit
you can view the documents on the osi
website for all the details
i don't have it open in front of me i
read it several hours ago so i
i can't comment specifically on that but
i don't believe there is a time limit
okay thank you very much you're welcome
thank you
any further questions from the committee
seeing none thank you again
representative
chair recognizes rebecca oller
good morning can you hear me we can
good morning great thank you uh and my
name is rebecca ohler i'm with the
department of environmental services and
i just wanted to
be able to respond to a couple of the
questions that just came up
um i'll take the second one first which
is the
time limit for the volkswagen funding
um there is in fact a time limit for
spending down the funds
we need to have the funds uh i believe
it's 80
expended within seven or eight years
um and if we if we don't if if we're not
at least
um at that level then we will not
qualify for any bonus funding
uh and we have to have the funds uh
fully expended
at ten years and if the if we do not
have it fully expended at 10 years any
remaining funds
are are removed from the new hampshire
beneficiary trust
so that if anybody has what's any
follow-up on that i'd be happy to
try to answer more on that yep uh thank
you very much uh i didn't have one
when was the settlement what was the
date
how many years has it been now it's uh
we are entering year three
of the settlement yes thank yes
so that the state got a total of about
ballpark 32
31 32 million dollars 15
of that can be spent on electric vehicle
charging infrastructure the remainder
is to be spent replacing diesel
equipment
the volkswagen violations were related
to their
their subterfuge of their of their
diesel emission systems
um and uh the
state has spent probably about six
million dollars so far replacing diesel
equipment
um so that gets me to the second uh part
of it which
was that there was not a big demand for
the uh vw funding for electric vehicle
charging infrastructure
and we did put out a solicitation for
what's called fast chargers which is the
sort of the highway charging where you
can get
a full charge in in 20 to 40 minutes
and we got uh
we did not get any qualifying responses
but that was not from lack of interest
it was a failure on our part to put
together a good solicitation
this was the first time we had done that
we
we just sort of missed a lot of the the
key points that we needed to uh to have
included
we have been working diligently to
revise that solicitation
uh we hope to get that out soon des is
working with the office of strategic
initiatives
but we are getting i get a call probably
at least
once every couple of weeks from somebody
asking me
when are we going to get the
solicitation out because people are
waiting for it
so i just wanted to clarify that we we
went out we did not get any
qualifying responses but it was our
fault
thank you any questions from the
committee
representative aaron yes thank you very
much uh mr chairman
um ms oller i'm interested to know
if if there's uh any kind of
documented plan by des
to you know in terms of dates
in terms of placement
where any of the charging stations may
be placed with money
thank you for your question um first to
clarify
the entity that sort of controls the vw
fund right now is the office of
strategic initiatives and des
works under an agreement with them
because they don't have
a big staff so we and and also because
des has more
uh experience in the realm of
transportation sector
so the there are no specific dates
on getting any particular infrastructure
out there is
one one unit that is being i hope
under construction right now at the
green street lot right around the corner
from the state house
and that will provide level two charging
there which is the sort of lower
you'd spend a couple of hours on a
but there is no specific timeline on
getting the funding out
other other than meeting that having the
funds spent
the appropriate amount within seven or
any further quote representative
thank you mr chairman and uh thank you
miss ohler for taking my
question um can you explain how these
charging stations work in other words if
i have an electric
vehicle and i approach this
um well if i plug in my car do i have to
like put in a credit card and stuff
how does this whole how does it all work
thank you um typically
uh yes it it would be just like
filling up with gas and that you would
you would put your credit card in and
and you would get your allotment of fuel
back out in
for whatever the agreed upon price is uh
the way that
that we are setting things up any of the
any unit built using state dollars which
would include the vw
funds would have to clearly specify what
the price is that you're going to pay
just like a gas pump it has to say the
amount per gallon on it
uh and um
i would it would be as seamless as that
there are
um i mean i don't know if you've ever
drive on 93 but there are tesla chargers
fast chargers at the
welcome centers on either side of 93 in
hooksett right now
and yeah they're just i mean on those
it's
the tesla is sort of a different
scenario and that they have their own
charging system
um unfortunately no other vehicle can
use a tesla charging system
um but uh yeah it would
most of them probably would not have a
swipe credit card it would either have a
tap system
and that's just because of security
they're not you can put a
charging station pretty much anywhere
it's not like a gas pump that has to
have a fire suppression system and
generally needs a tendon an attendant
there to make sure that there's not a
spill
and so one of the concerns with the
charging infrastructure is
safety in terms of somebody trying to um
uh put a card reader you know one of
those things that can grab your
card number so so wouldn't be using a
swipe
card but probably a tap card or um we'll
always have the option for
calling an 800 number and initiating a
charge over the phone
thank you very much you're welcome
from the committee representative
tillerson
thank you very much thank you mazzola
for taking my question just to better
understand how these
funds um can be used are they exclusive
to the
just the state for building
infrastructure or is there any avenue
for municipalities to access some of
these funds to expand
charging stations locally yes thank you
for your question
um the intent is it's not so
i guess let me back up the state is not
the one that is intending to build the
the charging infrastructure um i
i suppose theoretically some of it could
be used for
putting infrastructure on state-owned
property and and therefore the state
would be
making some investment but the bulk of
this is intended to be
public charging infrastructure um
we've as as sort of directed by the ev
charging commission
the initial priority is trying to get
the
charging infrastructure along the uh
major cars so i-93 95
89 and then some of the
some of the state routes you know 101 16
some of the some of the higher traffic
volume areas
and for those we would be uh soliciting
proposals from the private sector to say
tell us where you want to put it put it
tell us where
uh you know what type of equipment
you're going to put in what are your
hours of operation what's you know what
are what are all the details of how
you're going to operate this
and then we will be evaluating the
proposals that come in
and selecting the ones that meet based
on our evaluation the needs of the state
i just have a couple just for my own
notes
i said it was 15 of the volkswagen
settlement
yes so approximately 4.6 million okay
uh we follow the follow-up to that we've
heard about
tesla's charging stations currently on
a few times now who paid to put those
stations
tesla paid tesla paid to put those in
that's
it was part of their marketing strategy
and i must say it's worked pretty well
is that they they have built out their
own charging infrastructure across the
entire country
so if you own a tesla you can drive from
here to the west coast and know that
you're going to be able to
pick up a charge at you know
every everywhere you need it along the
way final follow-up for me
um do you know if uh ford gm
toyota or any of the other manufacturers
have that same goal
no the other manufacturers are not uh
pursuing a node their propriet their own
proprietary charging infrastructure
they are all using the the
um the charging mechanism
that would be found in a public charger
so there's
it's we're still sort of in the years of
you know the betamax versus sony
era where there's there's not yet full
agreement
among all of the world's manufacturers
as to what charging system is the best
so there are in addition to the tesla
charging uh
mechanism there are two others one is
primarily used by european and
and u.s manufacturers the other was just
primarily used
by japanese and korean manufacturers
um so on most well if
any charters that are built using the
volkswagen dollars the fast chargers
would would be required to be equipped
with both of the
sort of the american and the european or
american and asian
um charging nozzles so that it could be
used for any
vehicles and then the tesla
owners can also buy their own adapter
that would allow them to
to connect to that station as well so
basically it would be a universal
charging
and that's the the goal of the use of
the vw money is
is universal charging stations that's
the only thing it'll be spent on
thank you uh representative sykes did
you put your hand down
i did so i wanted just to make the point
that uh miss
ohler just made which is that the any vw
money being used would be for universal
charging systems so that it's
broadly available to the motoring public
i see one more question representative
o'hara thank you
mr chairman and just um your last
question made me think of
a question is this going to turn into
anything like our phones with chargers
like our manufacturers are going to
change the way they charge
and then now all of our equipment is
uh yeah i just went through that myself
with a new phone um
and i you know i obviously can't for
tell the future for what uh auto
manufacturers are gonna
do but i do not think so um this is
very well established uh you know
the most of the states around new
hampshire
and and as it was also pointed at quebec
are very well along in terms of
establishing charging infrastructure and
and have just thousands and thousands of
vehicles
in new hampshire we do have about we're
approaching 6 000
evs that are uh registered right now
and that's up from only about four
thousand last year and about two
thousand the year before that so we are
seeing
really significant increases year over
year
with electric vehicle adoption in new
hampshire and
availability of charging more broadly
across the street
a state will not only help new hampshire
residents adopt and operate these
vehicles but it will also
uh help support the tourists from all of
these states around us that have
you know in the tens of thousands of
electric vehicles
registered and they will then be able to
come to new hampshire
on vacation and know that they can they
can uh
top up their cars when they need to
thank you
it's
thank you mr chairman just a quick
question you um
mentioned that uh the universal chargers
would uh be able to adapt to be able to
buy an adapter if you had a tesla
to be able to use those in conjunction
with that
does tesla have any type of adapter that
people can use so they can use
their chargers good question and no
no
i see no further question
yes thank you representative thank you
mr chairman thank you miss over
one question if you choose to answer
this question in your opinion
do you feel why we perhaps
throughout the country except for tesla
you the other uh
car companies are not
putting in their own chargers is it
because perhaps they are waiting for the
public funds
to fund these charges so they won't have
to
i have no basis to have an opinion on
that i don't know why they're not
thank you thank you very much fine i see
no other questions i'm not going to ask
again i'll get you up there
thank you very much thank you thank you
for having me
um she recognizes
nino and i believe she
clean energy new hampshire with a
just promoted her she should be
hello can you hear me yes good morning
thank you uh hopefully this this lasts
because i've been having
some internet hiccups this morning but
hopefully you'll be able to hear me
throughout
um yes i do represent clean energy new
hampshire we're a non-profit that works
on
clean energy energy efficiency and all
things clean tech we also coordinate
drive electric new hampshire so we do
quite a bit of work on
electric vehicles and charging
infrastructure
i registered as neutral on the bill
because we
support most of it the first three
sections however we do have concerns
about section four regarding the rate
design
standards for electric vehicle charging
as
senator waters explained very well these
recommendations were taken
from a docket at the public utilities
commission and this was the poc staff's
recommendation
however i do have concerns that putting
them into statute would be
overly prescriptive and not allow
flexibility for the utilities
to design rates that work for each of
them
specifically we're also opposed to item
six regarding the appropriateness of
demand
charges on public charging demand
charges are actually really problematic
when they're applied to public charging
especially
high draw fast charging stations they
make the cost
extremely high especially early on when
you might have low utilization
so if the station is used once a month
you're going to get
a very high demand charge and that will
make
that one charge incredibly expensive
so we're actually work there's a lot of
work going on at the public utilities
commission
on electric vehicle charging rates
and so i would like to be able to
continue to work at the commission with
the utilities
on those rate designs there and
these are being used as sort of as i
said as guiding principles but i don't
i would not want to see them in statute
and saying that the utilities
shall comply with these exact
rate standards because i do think that
i'm happy to take any questions thank
you any questions from the committee
i hope i'm not ignoring anybody i just
see a couple of senators
on the list but no hands-free so i'm
assuming they're at this point
waiting to speak to a different part
bill
the last hand i do see is uh mr kevin
miller
a member of the public actually
represents chargepoint
thank you very much chairman walsh and
through you to the members
of the committee my name is kevin miller
i
represent a company called a chargepoint
we are supportive of sections one two
and three of the bill but
took a neutral position due to some
lingering concerns around uh
section four of the bill we would be
able to be supportive of the bill
if there were either changes to strike
that
section or to put in targeted changes to
to more effectively reach some of the
nuanced positions that were
previously described so really briefly
i'll give some background on chargepoint
since 2007 our company has been creating
the new fueling network to move all
people
on electric uh charges our business
model consists of selling
smart charging solutions directly to
businesses governments organizations
while offering them the tools to get the
most value out of providing ev charging
as an amenity
as a reason to attract new visitors or
new customers
or new tenants to locations
so you charge your car where you park
your car so it's not just a pit stop
experience along a highway it's also
when you get to home and work
and it can serve as a really valuable
grid asset when more charging takes
place over overnight hours so
briefly on section 1 we find that that
is consistent with the final report of
senate bill
517's ev charging station infrastructure
commission so we really appreciate
senator waters efforts on that um and
leadership on this issue as well as
efforts by
uh representative sykes and and smith on
that commission
we think that appropriately identifies
cost barriers section two would
you know clarify that ev charging
stations that receive public funding
should enable universal access which we
think is a common sense position
and section 3 would enable cities and
towns to to make decisions to provide
tax relief on the value of evsc which
would help to accelerate
and incentivize private investments i
think it's important to note that the
vast majority of all ev
charging investments necessary to
support electric transportation in new
hampshire will come from the private
sector
and that the state's allocation of
volkswagen diesel gate
mitigation funds would only ever account
for a small fraction of the total
infrastructure investment needed
to support ev charging for light medium
and heavy duty vehicles
i might also follow up on becky oller's
comments
about the lack of responses for new
hampshire's rfp for ev chargers
i'd say that the the absence of
qualifying bids shouldn't be viewed as a
lack of market interest
in of which there is uh significant um
however i also wouldn't say that
the lack of bids is a failure of des or
osi the technology involved with ev
charging is rapidly evolving and it's
no small feat to design an effective
program
there are examples around the country of
states that have tried
to issue programs that at first did not
receive
qualifying bids but then they took that
as a learning opportunity so it's a step
around the process
in an evolving technology um the one
piece
of feedback we give with concerns again
is in section four
which deals with some of the most
critical issues that will be necessary
to get right
in each of the 50 states is as
private investment increases as federal
investment opportunities are potentially
put on the table and i think one of the
key pieces to look at is the way that
electricity rates are designed because
the ongoing operating costs
for charging infrastructure can be a
significant barrier and
in a nutshell it's because commercial
and industrial
electricity rates were designed to treat
the big
loads like their long term factories
that are on for extended periods of time
and that's just not how
ev charging equipment operates so
by charging two types of electricity
rates for the volumetric consumption
for how much energy is used as well as
for how much power could be used at any
given time the demand charge
you create some imbalanced
rates that can really disincentivize
investment and actually are increasingly
being found to be
not cost based in how they assess those
costs so
i'd echo madeleine's comments that we're
looking at these issues
at the commission and in fact states
around the country are looking at ways
to
ensure that utilities can develop
alternatives to traditional demand-based
rates so i'd be happy to provide the
committee with a suggestion that you'd
be able to
amend paragraph six uh to instead of
saying that demand charges are
appropriate
great designs to note that actually to
the contrary alternatives to traditional
demand-based electricity rates may be
appropriate for high demand draw
ev supply equipment so providing
flexibility at the puc and for utilities
will be essential to
leverage more private investment
increase tourism increase economic
development opportunities
around new hampshire i'll pause right
there happy to take any questions
thank you very much are there any
thank you again sir thank you
okay um i went to my list here
people that were signed up in advance
i'm going to
soon i have some notifications of other
people that are speaking different
sections
but i do want to check with mr ted dears
from the new hampshire department for
environmental services
i have to assume signed up to speak this
is the section we want to speak to
the chair recognizes ted dears to see if
yeah i apologize i i'm on uh i'm
actually signed up for part
three oh okay well it was i was wrong
then
thank you let me put that down and we'll
talk in a little bit
uh okay that's all the hands i have
raised
on part one of the belt um let's give
the last call anybody else substitute
part one don't worry if i am uh
we do end up inadvertently missing
disappear interesting
keep going back and forth from the
panelists
all right well we'll give it a shot uh
that being said we'll move on to section
two
i got kicked out for a second okay but
you didn't need to okay
nope you're back okay part two of the
bill
mr chairman before you get going i'm
just gonna step out now so if brad can
take over for me and i'll
jump back in when i get back all right
thank you
thank you did you get that brad i guess
it did
all right thank you very much fred thank
you
uh okay part two of the bill uh a
removal of abandoned or disabled
vehicles by towing
um introduce that would be senator
birdsell
recognizes senator ferdinand i think i
hello can you hear me i can hear you now
oh
sorry i guess i was kicked out for a
couple seconds
um i just want to say thank you for the
committee for
hearing this bill and um for the record
my name is regina bertzell state senator
for district 19
which encompasses the towns of derry
hampstead and wynton
and i am the sponsor of part two
which is um it establishes the removal
of
abandoned or just disabled vehicles by
towing
this was a concerted effort by both the
state police
and the towing association i'm sure
you'll be hearing from both of them
to put together some legislation
that both could agree with i guess um in
the past
the whenever a car needs to be towed
there has been the
agreement between the state police and
the towing association there was
not an agreement um so
to bring some fairness to the
towing community
they've decided to a lot the new
hampshire state police
and the atone association got together
and what this bill allows is for the new
hampshire state police
when necessary to call from a rolling
out
sorry yeah a rolling list of tow
companies
to arrive to assisted scene um
the creation of this rolling list
establishes
uh both a fair and an equitable use of
the tow services by the new hampshire
state police
and it also requires to tow companies on
the rolling list to be fed
to be vetted and to meet the
professional standard requirements to
ensure
the safe and reliable total services so
again this was an agreement
um that was long a long time coming
between the
towing association and the new hampshire
state police
and again you're probably i presume the
towing
association is going to be online and
the state police to answer
any additional questions but i'll try
and answer any questions that you have
thank you thank you senator any
questions from the committee
the chair recognizes uh ralph cresta
he's signed up to speak in support of
the bill
representing new hampshire towing
association
can you hear me we can good morning good
morning
my name is ralph custer i'm the
president of new hampshire towing
association
the association supports this bill
uh and it's good uh for basically uh
organizing for the public
for the tours and also for the state
police we've been working on this bill
for
many years uh the president before me
was working on this particular bill
we've been trying to work with the state
police on keeping the tours accountable
and taking care of the public on on the
highways and
so this this bill is basically the
association
is for this particular bill at this time
i believe we're also going to hear from
lieutenant player and and about this
bill with the stated
state of new hampshire state police
but at this point we are for it and uh
anybody has any questions on it'd be
great
thank you very much are there any
representative thank you mr chairman
uh thank you mr cresta for uh testifying
today i'm interested to know
would somebody have to be a member of
your
association in order to be on this list
we try to most of the people are uh
it isn't um it isn't mandated by the
state
at this point um we we try to get most
of the members to
that are on the state police list to be
a member of our association yes thank
you
for the questions from the committee
seeing nothing
have a great rest of your day sir
um jay recognizes lieutenant player from
the new hampshire state police
good morning can you hear me good
morning thank you
uh i apologize um so i'm here
representing the
state department safety division of
state police i'm lieutenant andrew
player of new york state police troop g
um this was it as senator birdsdale
already said this
is a bill that was a long time coming uh
this does allow for a fair and equitable
way for
any towing business that wants to tow on
behalf of the new hampshire state police
to do so
it it lays a foundation of a the same
set of ground rules for everybody
as well as a as well as rules to uh
protect the public
uh from a tow business that may not be
acting in the best interest of everyone
uh so
again this is a long time coming it's
something that like we say allows for
protection of the towing industry as
well as for the
general public and it is something that
the state police has worked uh
for a considerable amount of time with
the towing association in order to uh
to come to something that does benefit
everyone i'd be happy to answer any
questions that any of the board members
may have
any questions from the committee
representative crawford
thank you mr chairman thank you
lieutenant for taking my question uh
the list it's a rolling list so the
troopers would
call the first person on that list and
if they don't answer they go to the next
person or do they give that
first person a chance to respond uh in a
uh you know in a short period of time or
how does that work could you explain it
to me please
yes so the way that it works is the uh
the the calls will actually come from
our dispatch center so when a trooper on
the side of the road request a tow truck
our dispatch center will contact the uh
the first towing company
at the top of the list and they do give
them typically a reasonable amount of
time to try and answer that phone call i
don't believe it's just an instant
three rings and hang up they will try
and uh make contact with them they
if if they're unable to make a response
uh if no one answers the phone they
leave a message nobody calls back within
a short
period of time then they will go on to
the next person on the list
and work their way through the list that
see no other questions from the
committee so thank you very much
thank you very much thank you for taking
it awesome okay that's
it looks like once you speak to part two
i'll ask one more time
uh if anybody else wishes to speak to
part two of the bill raise your hand
please
none so we'll move on to part three
again
uh if i've missed anybody we can always
go back let's try to get organized
uh part three of the bill the municipal
winter maintenance certification program
[Music]
another private sponsor at this portion
is senator moore so i did see his name
there
thank you mr chair good morning
good morning for the record i am senator
chuck morris i represent senate district
22 which includes the towns of salem
atkinson plaistow and pelham
i'm the prime sponsor of part three of
senate bill 131
which makes a few changes to the salt
applicators program
i first got involved with the salt
applicator program
because of the i-93 project
which could be up to 20 years ago now as
part of the lawsuit regarding the
project
the state was required to reduce the
amount of salt
runoff impacting local waterways state
has been working to use best practices
to reduce salt use and the current
certification program works with private
contractors to help reduce
their salt usage under current law only
private contractors can get the
certification
this bill would allow the state to
certify municipal programs as well
in the bill itself sections 2 4
and 7 make a few technical changes to
the salt applicators program
mostly to better define the differences
between an individual
and a subordinate certificate while
while the balance of the bill allows the
municipalities to have their programs
certified by des
this bill is a win-win for
municipalities
because they will save money through
reduced salt usage and it helps to keep
our waterways clean
i know des is on this call and they
certainly can answer some technical
questions
thank you sir any questions from the
committee
seeing none thank you again thank you mr
champ
okay um mr ted dears new hampshire
department of
my environmental services in support of
um i also um originally allowed him just
to speak
i just promoted to a panel let's see if
good morning all right thank you very
much for uh
for streaming me in i appreciate that uh
uh mr chair members of the committee
for the record my name is ted dears and
i'm the administrator of the watershed
management bureau
at the new hampshire department of
environmental services
it's my great pleasure to be with you
this morning to talk about
uh sb 131 part three
uh as senator morse so capably
introduced this bill
it is about adding a municipal component
to our voluntary
salt applicator certification program
otherwise and better known as our green
snow pros
um we have trained uh about 2
000 people over the last uh six or seven
years in how to protect public safety
while reducing the amount of chlorides
this amount of salt that goes on our
roads
this is becoming a major issue in a
number of areas around the state
where we are losing water supplies due
to high salt
content we see streams that are greatly
impacted by high salt
and you also it impacts our
infrastructure it tears up our bridges
it tears up our concrete
uh it's expensive for for landowners and
landscaping
so these are some of the reasons why
reducing salt is important this bill is
important because
it does allow for
municipalities become certified there
are a number of reasons why we heard
from the municipalities
that they want this a couple of them are
outlined in my
in my letter there's a testimony letter
that was sent from the commissioner
but the one of the key ones is that
there are some regulatory requirements
through an epa permit on stormwater and
as part of that permit in areas that are
impacted by chlorides
they need to essentially have the kind
of program that we're offering in place
and so by having the certification
program it allows them to comply
easily with that how we think this is
going to work is a little different
than our certified uh commercial
applicator program in that
we're going to be certifying entire
programs so so a municipal program that
actually is that winter maintenance
so they'll have certain requirements uh
which we'll do some rulemaking to
establish by working with the
the stakeholders to do that um and it'll
basically have many of the same
requirements but it'll focus on on sort
of the broader vision of an entire
community
uh looking at making sure that their
their applicators
the the plow operators are certified
that they're trained
um that they're doing some accounting of
their salt usage
uh that they're calibrating their
equipment these are the things that
research has shown really dramatically
reduces the amount of salt use
so now i'm going to stop there and just
see if there's
any other questions because i know you
have a lot of work on your table today
thank you sir um let the committee go
first any quiet
okay representative thank you mr chair
and thank you mr dears for your
testimony today
i am interested to know if you
anticipate any increased
uh costs for the municipalities
in order to participate in these
programs
thank you for the question um this is
a very inexpensive proposition and in
fact
what's been found in most of the
circumstances
around the country where people have
really gone down this road
of of you know doing better calibration
of doing better training
for their employees in municipal
settings
is that they end up saving money that
these changes
more than pay for themselves in reduced
chloride use
so um even when there's um
even when there's equipment purchases
some people get really advanced into
this they where
they use different kinds of equipment
city of concord has what's called
live edge plows which instead of a
single blade all across the front of the
plow it's built of
a number of you know six or seven or
eight
articulated uh sections within that that
allows you to get uh
as i like to put it it's like a closer
shave it's like one blade versus five on
your bic
razor um with the more blades you get a
closer
shave which reduces the the the the ice
even that saves money because they don't
have to plow as many times you get a
better plow the first time around so
things like that tend to save money and
there will be a fee associated with this
to cover administrative costs but it'll
be
pretty nominal the fees that are are
paid by our
unit our commercial applicators and we
have not set the fee yet that would
happen during rule making
um in cooperation with the
municipalities um
are in the few hundred dollar range so
and that that's just for training
that that kind of cost could be for the
training of the staff
of the municipality in the road
department
yeah thank you for the question the the
way that it works generally is that we
have different training programs set up
and one of the things that we've done
and as part of the overall bill and this
happens in a lot of different
communities
is that we've set up a mechanism where
especially for some of the larger
communities
they can actually do their own training
so we have a curriculum that they can
use
it has a set of of elements that they
have to hit within that training a
certain amount of time
that they have to train for and they can
apply to us and we set up an approved
training program
and you know we find that for a lot of
our larger uh both commercial
side and i think this will probably be
the case on the the um
on the uh the municipal side as well is
that some of these larger communities
will do that
we also provide training through unh so
the t-squared program which many of you
are probably familiar with that gets
dollars from
dot at unh it's that technical transfer
program which
works with road agents they run the
rhodes scholar program
through that they also do training on
winter maintenance so
there are many different options for
people to get training thank you
thank you very much thank you mr dears
for taking my question you touched
this on this briefly um with
representative erin's question
you were getting very specific about um
equipment and and um different training
skills for um operators does it get in
does your program get involved with
actual products that are
put down on the road like i know um in
my town they have begun
spraying what i think is called brian on
the streets is is that considered a
greener alternative um so overall you
know
this program takes in the whole spectrum
of everything that can be done to be
more environmentally safe
great great question and you hit the
nail on the head um
in day indeed the way that we sort of
see this program being
rolled out is in in multiple sort of
levels there's going to be
i think what i sort of i think about it
is kind of a bronze silver gold approach
where the bronze approach is going to be
just making sure everybody gets trained
making sure your equipment is calibrated
and make sure you're counting your
how much salt you're using then there
might be a a silver
level which would include beginning to
dabble in brine
brine is incredibly important if you
really want to
reduce chlorides brine is critical
because
brine what salt does and this is one of
the things that goes on in our training
program
is that the salt isn't really to melt
the ice
the salt is to keep the ice from
adhering to the pavement so that you can
plow the ice away
that's the purpose of using road salt
and what brine does is it gets out ahead
of that
it's already on the road and so as that
ice starts to form
up it has a it has that salt layer
underneath which allows it to not adhere
and so what it does a couple of things
it helps you not have to get out
as quickly onto the storm which saves
you time
and overtime in the morning and
oftentimes these storms happen at two
o'clock in the morning as
as you all know um so it saves a little
time there but it also
means that you are more effective in
your mechanical plowing
um which is what really redu removes the
snow and ice
so brian is an incredibly important
piece and and as communities get more
sophisticated in their knowledge
then they begin to employ some of those
it's not required
as part of this but it would be
recognized as they
increased their sophistication in their
winter maintenance activities
that they would be rewarded with that
through different levels of
certification so that's
that's kind of the idea but again we're
going to work through this in rule
making with the communities to see
what's going to serve them
best thank you
senator gracie yes thank you mr chairman
um i just wanted to mention that i was a
graduate of the t-square program
took a program in utilization of grinds
and other things
as well as the storm water management uh
sections that they have there as well
and the contamination of our of our
groundwater from
uh from from road salts and i found the
program to be very helpful
i was very surprised because that
municipalities weren't already being
certified
i think this is great that you're doing
this and i just wanted to say that the
program that they did have at the
university
uh in the t-square program is just
phenomenal and
all the communities that i worked with
did
use alternative methods and reducing
thank you representatives great to see
you again and i think you hit uh hit
that on the head is that
t-squared does a phenomenal job and in
fact recently uh with some changes in
leadership they've improved
dramatically i think their operations uh
we look forward to increasing our
interactions and our partnerships with
them we have partnerships with other
people as well we actually have an
online course that was developed through
a group up in ontario
um and we're doing a lot of partnerships
now with minnesota
and uh with new york state on a number
of different things so
any other questions from the committee i
do have one
um representative actually
stole some of my thunder talking about
the
grinds but more specifically is the pbs
doing any research where is magnesium
fluoride specifically included in this
i know i believe or you could
correct me if i'm wrong but it helps
with less
salt using the magnesium chloride but
does the magnesium chloride itself have
any effect on the waterways
thank you mr chair uh excellent
questions um
so what magnesium chloride does is it
allows
for uh salt to work at lower
temperatures
so regular old rock salt doesn't work at
all below about 15 degrees maybe 20
degrees it depends on the
atmospheric conditions and how much
moisture is out there
it doesn't work it has to get into
solution and so
um if you just if you if it's 15 degrees
out and you have a piece of ice and you
just throw a rock salt on there it's
nothing but rock salt
it's not it's nothing but traction at
that point just because of the
you're better off putting sand down um
what magnesium chloride does is it
allows you to treat at a lower
lower temperature so what most people do
and this is a common practice in fact in
in concord they
they pre-treat their sodium chloride
their regular
rock salt with a a mixture
of a little bit of magnesium chloride
um and a little bit of some other kind
of surfactant um
oftentimes what's used is uh basically
high fructose corn syrup um so
it essentially what it does is it allows
you to stick a little bit better to the
road
so that you don't see you know in the
old days and sometimes you do still see
you're driving behind a truck that's
that's loading out
rock salt and that stuff is just
bouncing all over and half of it's
bouncing off the side of the road
that's just waste that's just money down
the drain as well as salt into the
environment
so what magnesium chloride does is it
helps you to use less
sodium chloride at lower temperatures
now the one problem with magnesium
chloride for those of you who remember
your high school chemistry
is that nacl which is sodium chloride
only has one chloride attached to each
molecule
of sodium magnesium chloride is
magnesium chloride two
and so there are two chlorides to every
molecule of magnesium
so if you were to use the same amounts
of magnesium chloride and sodium
chloride you'd actually be putting down
twice
the chlorides and it's chloride which is
toxic to fish
so what you what ends up happening is
this is why you use these in in
in very specific amounts and it
and what concrete has found and what
other communities have found is that by
doing this sort of
mix and also by pre-wetting their sodium
chloride sometimes what you'll see is a
are are saddle tanks on the backs of
these spreaders
that actually squirt a little bit of
water onto the ice onto the salt
before it goes out onto the street and
that gets it going into solution
it kind of does the same thing so it's a
really important component
to what people are doing but yet this is
one of the
things that you learn in our classes is
that you have to do that in the right
way if you're
actually going to reduce your chloride
use
well i'll give myself a follow-up you
didn't answer my question it is
specifically covered in the
certification process
i won't go any further on
magnesium chloride i've done a lot of
research on it what it does to our
infrastructure
and our vehicles is devastating in my
opinion
is the department looking at maybe
things that work
as well to reduce salt that may not be
as plastic
or corrosive as magnesium chloride
sure that's a great question and i
appreciate it this is an
area in which this is one of the key
places that i'm having conversations
with
my uh my colleagues throughout the
country
is we do not have a great capacity
for at like like a a chloride
alternative test bed somewhere
this is something that i've raised with
senator shaheen
in meetings with her i have other other
states are raising that with their
federal representatives is that we don't
have
like one place you can go where there's
a test bed
of new products there are all kinds of
interesting products out there out in
duluth
they use potassium acetate on their
bridges
for the very same reason that you
suggest that using
any kind of chloride product has the
potential to cause a
corrosion so this is an incredibly
important area of research we would love
to see unh get
involved in some of that kind of
research um
and and this is one of the things that
we're talking about with our federal
uh compatriots is to see if we could
somehow set up
kind of this third party testing ability
as they do in other technologies
to see if there's some ways that we can
improve that there are places out in
wisconsin they use
cheese waste in minnesota they use beer
waste
or vice versa whichever part of the
country you have to be in
um you know so there are some of those
um and the question is is what are the
downsides of some of that
those products and that's that's what
really it is a little bit of a wild wild
west out there where there's some people
selling snake oil
um and you know so that that i think
that that this is a major challenge that
we need to address as a nation
thanks for letting me go off the rails a
little bit uh i see representative erin
yes thank you very much mr chairman and
mr dears
i have a question about um if you if you
might want to
clarify or talk a little bit about this
liability that's limited for winter
maintenance
section here it seems to me
talks about that if if municipality
gets itself certified that it will help
alleviate any uh liability for
perhaps accidents happening on the road
or can you
clarify that a little for me yes thank
you representative this
this is uh this is an important issue
this is one of the things that was
key uh in the uh commercial assault
applicator
uh legislation so i just want to just
sort of give the history here real quick
before we jump into
this current bill and so one of the
things that we heard from contractors
over the years
is that the slip and fall cases were one
of the reasons why they over salted
because if anybody went out there they
wanted to show that not only had they
done what they were supposed to do
they were going to have so much salt
that you couldn't see the ground for
there was so much salt there's no way
that anybody could prove that they were
at fault in a slip and fall case
and that's just more salt that's needed
that's just waste
um and so we put this liability
provision in
um and again thanks to senator morse uh
for for getting that through um
and it's it's it's unique in the nation
there are many other states that are
trying to get this into place
um for the very same reasons that we did
and it's based kind of on the ski area
legislation that says that the ski areas
are doing base they're not negligent you
can't sue them
for you know slipping and falling on a
mountain because the whole point
is to slip and fall down a mountain um
so you know this
is um the the history of that what we
wanted to make sure
is that you know municipalities like the
state already have sovereign immunity
so they really can't be sued for slip
and fall cases
if they're doing what they're supposed
to be doing that is they're not
negligent
so what we wanted to make sure was by
doing this bill by having the
certification
we didn't somehow
mess up their sovereign immunity and so
that's what that line in that section is
about
is to make sure that that that just
because they're getting trained and
using less salt
doesn't make them any more liable for
for slip and fall cases and this we ran
back
the the new hampshire municipal
association to make sure that this is
uh that this was appropriate for the
communities before this went forward and
and certainly in the in the senate um
new hampshire
uh municipal association uh testified in
favor of this bill
thank you so much for for that
absolutely
any other questions
thank you very much sir thank you so
much have a great day
it was um any other questions
on section three of the build if you do
raise your hand down please
see our list of attendees is shrinking
and i see no other hand so we'll move on
to section four
once again if i miss you don't hesitate
to raise your hand we can go back
so moving on to section four of the bill
eligibility for issuance of the
non-drivers picture identification card
uh senator waters has already introduced
it
i do know that uh representative sykes
is also on the bill if you'd like to
speak
on it at all if not
i'll ask anybody to raise their hands
uh mr chairman i only caught part of
what you were saying
to me or about me could you repeat that
oh sure i've just given you the
opportunity i know you're a co-sponsor
and i know senator
i mean senator waters had to leave i
didn't know if he wanted to
to speak a little bit on this or not if
not i'm just trying to move it to the
next speaker
yeah and they'll move to the next
speaker i think that senator waters did
a decent job of introducing
she recognizes uh director leckie
elizabeth
from the department of motor vehicles
she may be here for this one i'm not
sure
good morning mr chairman members of the
committee how are you doing this morning
good morning how are you um thank you
for recognizing me
i think senator waters really did a
great job introducing this section of
the bill as well we have requested
the addition of this language for a
couple of reasons
the main one being as we are moving
forward with the implementation of the
state-to-state verification system
alongside many other states it's really
critical that we don't have
credentials or instances where people
hold
two valid credentials in the state of
new hampshire
being a valid driver's license as well
as a valid non-driver
identification card that really makes
the implementation of the state-state
system a lot easier
and a lot easier to manage when new
hampshire residents
move out of state as well so with that
i'll um
just open um it up to any questions that
the committee might have
thank you director any questions from
thank you thank you director bolecki i
just have a quick question on that last
section about the disposition of
fees um is that just because you're
taking out this section
about the the granite state i forget
what it's called now
the advantage program um which was for
senior citizens or
the the part about committee on aging
um you are well you are correct it is
the um
the card issued if you can if you look
back to
section or paragraph three section two
uh under identification card it does
recognize that pursuant to rsa 260 21 1c
that golden granite state discount card
was
issued so there was a fee related to
that that was
um that was divided out in accordance
with that section
in section three so i think it's just
removing and cleaning up
any references related to the language
that's being deleted
okay thank you and oh follow up
thank you i just wanted to clarify that
um we spoke yesterday about what i
brought up with senator waters about
removing the line about
our disabled residents and you would
agree that that would be um
wouldn't affect the intent of the
section yes and thank you for bringing
that up i think that's a great catch and
it's a nice way to really clarify the
intent of the bill
um so i think it just simplifies it and
yes i reviewed and i don't have
any issues with the proposed language
thank you very much
thank you any other questions from the
committee
okay section 5 is a certificate of
voting
safety by title
[Music]
the private sponsor of this portion of
the bill is senator birdsall is she
hello are you there we are good morning
okay
great i'm sorry i'm working too so i'm
trying to figure out which one is which
um again uh for the record my name is
senator regina bertsell um
state senator for district 19 which
encompasses the towns of ham
derry hampstead and windham and
i am also the sponsor um on the voting
certificate and basically this was a
request
from the department of safety
um the date of births
we're just canceling out the date of
births because they're already passed
um for the certificate so if there's
any um questions that you have
i'm sure director bill lickey will
be glad to um
thank you very much see no questions
from the committee either
thank you again um
chair recognizes uh captain dunlevy
good morning mr chair can you hear me
good morning
thank you mr chair and honourable
members of the committee my name is tim
dunleavy and i am the
captain of the marine patrol unit of the
state police i thank you for the
opportunity to testify this morning i'll
be very brief
this portion of senate bill 131
i consider housekeeping in its truest
sense if you look at the language that
is being deleted
it simply is referring to the phase-in
process of the statute that required
voters
uh to get a a certificate
showing a proof of boating education uh
that has long since
passed going back to 2008 so now
when voters look at the statute
attorneys as well as the courts
uh it actually creates a little bit of
confusion as to why those dates are
still there
so by eliminating the dates and just
simply saying you need the certificate
which is indeed the case now uh it
eliminates a bunch of confusion
and again it's truly just a housekeeping
measure and i'm happy to answer any
questions you may have
thanks again thank you very much uh
five let's see no hands raised so we'll
move on to the final section
of the bill section six allowing
emergency medical services chiefs and
fire chiefs to issue decals
good morning chairman walsh in uh
members of the committee and i uh my
name is susan for the record my name is
suzanne prentiss i am the
state senator from district five uh i'd
like to say hi to my colleague from
lebanon
george sykes because that's uh that's
where i live and i cover eight
communities on the connecticut river
valley i am also a
licensed paramedic in the state of new
hampshire and i've been asked by the new
hampshire association of emts
to make available to them the same that
is made available
to members of the fire service to have
uh
decals for their for their license
plates again just
as this was just as the the full time
and the volunteer firefighters were made
available
for last last i believe this was last
session
um this work was done so this is to
allow for ems to have the decals for
their plates
and i wrote language i i found it
actually something that
needs to be changed but i wrote the
language that would allow emergency
medical services chiefs and fire chiefs
um to issue this to current members or
retired members because
not all ems is delivered different ways
in the states sometimes it's under a
fire department
sometimes it's an a soul it's a a
completely different entity so
the fire chiefs would still need to have
um their say
in issuing these um these decals and i
also if i may um chairman walsh i
recognized recently that in
um so on line 9
under this section um this multi-use
decal plate on a motor vehicle
owned and registered by an emergency
services personnel it should be
mirror what the firefighters part
section which is owned
it has to be registered but should be
owned or leased um and i did not include
least when i when i wrote the language
and i honestly just
just recently caught that yep
seeing none thank you very much
does anybody wish anybody else wish to
speak on
any section of the bill actually that's
my uh last hand raised
we missed you before going through the
sections now's the time
or this section now is the time
seeing none i'm going to close the
public hearing on
okay
that was interesting yeah
um the only other agenda item i have
today we are certainly not going to try
to execute this today
i do have the room scheduled for next
tuesday
um what time i haven't decided yet but
it will be next tuesday get a lot of
possibly one last minor amendment and
correction
uh the only thing i've got that we can
go over now as far as committee business
site
everybody receive the side by sides for
the bills that have been
and the way this works i just want to
follow the committee obviously
either have to concur non-concur
or uh non-concur requested committee
conference the changes that they've made
in my opinion are pretty simple we can
go over them real quick if you'd like
i did also just discover this morning a
couple of problems potentially
and so what i guess what i'm looking at
is uh i'll
i'll go through these and let me know if
anybody objects to was concurring that's
a good way to start
uh health spill 100 which is the
crossing the painted line i guess before
i do this has everybody seen it do i
raise our hands
does anybody did everybody get the email
yeah
okay committed all right well i can run
it by quick
and again this is non-binding uh it's
just a polling of the committee
uh anyway uh the that's the ability to
cross this a solid
painted line uh the senate removed the
name
chapman which is typical we we don't
usually
name and statute our laws we nickname
them
so taking that out i have no problem
with personally
and it also adds wheelchairs
or mobility scooter or devices to that
section
so they're included in a reason to be
able to cross that line
so myself i'm leaning towards the concur
i see no issue
with the changes made by the senate we
okay uh house bill 174 the cap bill
notoriously um the only change they made
there was
again they removed the name of the bill
uh that the name of the cat
arrow so it'll only be nicknamed
arrow's law it won't be in our statues
okay the senate may change and these are
the only two i have i'm still waiting
for 251 they haven't voted on that
the senate is still holding on to house
bill 222
and 224
i guess just to see what we do with this
one apparently
um welcome to the end of the process
uh unfortunately i was looking through
423 and 424 they made changes
uh 423 to remove two senators added
uh somebody from the municipal
association unfortunately totals eight
people
uh 424. they went to one senator from
two
added uh somebody from the cellular
telecommunications and internet
association
or a designee which is fine a member of
the public appointed by the speaker
fine uh unless i made a mistake i see
that one evening eight people too
typically committee should be a mod
these are steady committees um if i can
get some advice that the
odd number isn't that important i'll
reach out to you
with that opinion this is 423
423 24. unless i got it wrong this
morning before we started
uh i with the changes they both equal
the number of people on the committee so
it's just not usually how it's done
so i want to confirm those before we
pull those
uh hopefully i'll get an answer before
however i don't even know if we're going
to have an answer on the other three
that they're holding by tuesday
so those we might have to do remote
after in terms of getting an opinion
on the committee before we get to the
house where ask the house
what they want to do mr chairman
thank you um who
from whom are you asking an opinion
about the even numbered
uh members of us of a study committee
yeah i was going to check with
leadership or what's your opinion
do you think it matters no i just i i
i mean it just all it will do is uh
when an even number would be most most
often these types of commissions and
committees
offer resolutions to be included in the
report
and they vote on them and if it's an
even number and it comes out
high unexpectedly the the motion would
still fail
so i mean it's not it's not an
insurmountable
problem again i don't think it is i i
mean i i
if it's not an issue whether i check
with the speaker or the clerk
i'm okay i'm okay with working with them
the way they are they are just studying
commissions yeah
in my five terms on the transportation
committee this is the first time we've
ever had an odd number it's always been
an even number of
you know representatives yeah it's
always been true that's true on the
committee itself you're right yeah and
the committee itself it's always been 20
you know and it just is what it is so
anyways my
my point is that i don't think it's a
insurmountable problem no i think it's
not a problem
personally i'm certainly not
recommending that you not concur
okay they're fine and should move on so
i have a quick question sorry mr
chairman just a quick question
um i'm just curious if you or
representative sykes or anyone who's
been around
had an opinion on the member of a public
being appointed to house bill 424 i i
know i was listening to the hearing that
day and there was a little bit of a
discussion
has are there committees that are
established that just have a
generic member of the public without any
definition of
what their interest should be yeah i
have seen them before
there was some discussion on it when the
senate made their changes
um they were going to actually have the
senate president
appoint one as well uh but i didn't see
that in there but
it just gives the speaker a little
levity to find somebody that you know
fill the seat and that will fit in with
the uh with the committee there again i
think they were looking for the odd
number but just didn't have somebody on
okay thanks i don't see it as a big deal
i've already mentioned uh
to the speaker that he's got an
uh have you have yet the only other
thing uh for the next week or so
um we do have some retained bills
um i believe you can all check
and see so in this next week's time if
you can take a look at those retain
bills
and if any anybody uh or any one of the
topics
piques your interest uh next week we can
finalize
uh establishing subcommittees to work on
those retained bills
of the summer and fall months or
whatever whatever the
volunteers seek to do so again we'll
leave that alone today
just a week to look at it
speak to your fancy if you'd like to
volunteer it would be greatly
appreciated
look for the posting for the executive
session
you